so it's a pleasure to be here Harvard
Business School has one of the oldest
agribusiness programs in the world in
fact one of my colleagues ray Goldberg
who started the program I won't tell you
how many years ago really invented the
idea of agribusiness and the school
tracks the entire food supply chain from
fertilizer and seed through growing and
distribution down to restaurants and
houses what I want to show you is not
that supply side which we actually
understand pretty well in the advanced
industrialized countries but research
into the nature of demand for food and
how that has changed over time and
what's striking is just how different in
otherwise similar advanced
industrialized countries the nature of
what we think of as food or culinary
cultures have become and just to give
you an example so in Japan the caloric
intake has fallen systematically from
nineteen seventy eight till today from
about 2,400 calories they were working
in factories that needed a lot of
calories to about 1800 calories per
capita today they have no obesity
problem and when you compare that to the
US and then Europe and also along other
dimensions of nutrition the differences
are striking and I think from the US
perspective the question is if we are so
rich why is that we don't eat better
food and what I want to argue is that
there is really a not a cultural
explanation it's really not about the
power of agribusiness but instead that
there is an important political moment
that happens in all of these countries
and it's at these critical junctures
that you really set off in a new
trajectory and there there are two
things that happen that really matter
for better for worse war turns out to be
very important for national food systems
and then more importantly I think the
transformation of the structure of the
family and especially the shifting role
in identity of women in home food
production I want to show you just a
little glimpse at both of those elements
and let me just say one motivating thing
why would we worry about this we'll look
if you think it's about the changing
role of the families American families
have changed again and I think it at
least looking historically at how these
transformations have
then open the possibility for imagining
a new transformation and how we think
about food and identity and family so
let me show you the history though so
first on war so of course war leads to
innovation that is absolutely true and
food as well so it turns out France in
the 19th century is basically at war all
the time and they invent almost all of
the major food processed food products
so canning but what i should say most of
these food innovations were developed
under prizes offered by the state to
develop something mainly for the army so
canning was developed under the napoleon
the first Napoleonic Wars Napoleon the
third made a prize for oleo margarine
and then frozen foods comes during a
time of significant food shortage after
a big big military loss and what's so
fascinating is that first of all the
guys who invented these things most of
them made no money on them so they
basically died poppers and it all the
way they invented these products it
really is other people who take them up
and start to adopt them so Borden who
goes to France and learns about
autoclaving in order to can milk ends up
making a killing when the Civil War hits
in the US and sells an enormous amount
of food to both the North and the South
bird's-eye seafood also his freezing
technology also comes from France he has
a story about going to the North to
learn how to flash-freeze but it's
really a French technology that he
borrows and again this really takes over
the American market as refrigeration
comes online so what look war is
important the important thing about the
war though it turns out to be not the
supply of food but really the demand of
food so what do we see let me tell you
the two stories briefly we see the
emergence of quality grades and food so
the beef grading almost every other kind
of grading happens during first world
war one in World War two and what is it
designed for look at basil basically
matches the structure of military ranks
so you want the officers the better meat
on you think I'm joking this is like
really true and so they end up paying
farmers more for our better cuts of meat
than lesser cuts of meat and somewhere
between a half and three quarters of
food output in the u.s. is going either
to RM
Terry or to our allies in Europe and so
this is a critical moment for the u.s.
system and they are worried about
nutritional content so we start adding
all of our dietary supplements during
this period in France they the only
instruction during a German occupation
is that the farmer should leave their
land so there is no food production
they're going to try to starve out the
the Germans and the only thing that
happens in France is not about spoot
standardization but the the Vichy regime
does an amazing job actually of
standardizing pots and pans in France
and so all the beautiful creuset pans
you see their designs were developed by
the the German occupation government and
they're all of their obsession is about
how many calories do you need because
they know that even after the war
they're not going to have a lot of food
and they want to try to get people up to
the minimum oh I did something wrong
yeah there we go where's there are a
couple of other things I'll show you a
couple pitchers on new housing comes
online and what is that new housing look
like well the French borrow this idea
that the kitchen should be efficient so
in the 20s the kind of efficiency
movement is hit American kitchens by the
30s American housewives are fed up with
it and nobody does needs anymore the
French love the idea and so all the
post-war housing has these tiny little
kitchens that contains the female food
preparers this is what they look like
this is like on a grandiose scale these
were drawings that were drawn during the
war and that become the template for
post-war housing and then there's this
problem of electricity so there's
electrification in the u.s. americans by
all these stoves and refrigerators the
French have inadequate electricity to
run almost any household equipment so
the stuff is available but it's
expensive and there's not enough power
to run it and the big technologies and
France become the pressure cooker and
then there's just enough equaling of
currency to run a coffee grinder this is
the stuff that they're being tempted by
but nobody buys the stuff because they
basically can't afford it and they can't
run it okay let me just tell you this
last thing about women and the
transformation of the family the so what
happens at the same time these wars are
going on is that women start entering
the professional workforce a lot of this
is triggered by the war is obviously and
and that causes a renegotiation of the
status and role of women and families
and it looks really different in the two
countries and thus I would say is a
broad political story so what happens in
the US women become professionalised
outside of the house the training that
women receive is really scientific
training so there's a big focus in home
economics apartments that emerged in the
small colleges and then larger state
universities in the u.s. to focus on
that they form a very early productive
alliance with American food producers
the early FDA would have been killed if
not for this alliance the food producers
want to get the small producers out of
business so they can consolidate their
market and these early women want to
have as little time in the kitchen so
they can pursue professional careers let
me just show you what happens in France
it's completely different there is no
household equipment manufacturing to
speak of and food business doesn't exist
month and so women join up with
Catholics and labor in a project to keep
women in the household and of course
eventually that disappears but all of
the early post-war legislation that
relates to food gets driven by these
difference alliances and they push the
countries in different directions let me
just leave you with one slide and you
know the causal mechanism but this is
not spurious any indicator of food
quality shows this relationship
eculizumab
you